[Applaudissements]
c'est un transgenre qui fait un
changement de 500 direct pas du tout
donc c'est celle qui a été choisie pour
nous représenter le 13 mai à Liverpool
en Angleterre elle a déjà été approché à
une année il y a deux ans à peu près et
là ils ont choisi une québécoise et
évidemment il y a certaines personnes
comme toi qui sont scandalisés sauf que
c'est déjà arrivé en gardant avec
Natacha Saint-Pierre et on était arrivé
4e bien sûr et Céline Dion
c'est un concours qui n'a plus aucun
sens tu peux prendre quelqu'un c'est tu
représentes tu peux prendre un Allemand
pour représenter la France qui chante en
anglais
on a 15000 émissions de radio crochet en
France de télé crochet enfin pour
chanter on n'est pas capable de trouver
quelqu'un qui nous représente obliger
d'aller chercher au Québec déjà dans le
Québec ils nous emmerde
on les adore on les adore mais bon
est-ce qu'il y a des animateurs des
Français qui vont faire de la télé au
Québec alors ça veut dire quelque chose
j'ai un vrai coup de gueule parce qu'on
en a reçu hein des animateurs québécois
des gars ou des Natasha St-Pier qui
viennent animer des émissions on en a eu
plein Grégory Charles dans ce n'est pas
sur TF1 Julie Snyder moi Gilbert Rosalie
au Québec va effectivement avec ton
accent français
c'est la première fois depuis longtemps
que France Télévisions ne fait plus le
fameux concours où ce sont les Français
qui existent là la dernière fois en
France donc peut-être compris
et c'est 2003 donc bonne chance ma
chérie si on gagne on dirait que c'est
le Québec qui a gagné quoi donc c'est
débile
on a choisi cette femme pour représenter
la France
et deux mais pourquoi on va chercher
quelqu'un du Québec alors que c'est un
truc qui s'appelle l'Eurovision avec des
fesses
de gagner pardon mais quand tu es
footballeur algérien tu joues pas dans
l'équipe de France tu joues avec toi
national non pardonation
en plus tu sais ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que il y a une espèce d'échec
chez nous on a été foutu sur 66 millions
de Français de trouver une chanteuse
française voilà et est-ce qu'elle va
chanter en français moi bien sûr
avec la révélation de la chanson début
février elle est en cours de
finalisation d'accord
oui enfin elle peut très bien pour
gagner il faut chanter pour chanter en
anglais pour gagner peut-être décidé de
chanter il est arrivé super bien